Millie Bobby Brown just got engaged to
Jake Bon Jovi at 19 years old so let's
take a look at some other celebrities
who got married as teenagers when Olivia
Wilde was 18 she eloped with filmmaker
Tau raspoli he was 27 at the time they
got married and they divorced after
eight years at 17 years old Macaulay
Culkin married Rachel Miner she was 18
and they were only married for two years
I could not find a picture of him but
Solange got married to her high school
sweetheart Daniel Smith at 17 years old
and they were also married for two years
Drew Barrymore got married at 19 years
old to Jeremy Thomas he was a bar owner
and he was 31 when they got married and
they split up after only 19 days at 19
years old Kim Kardashian married music
producer Damon Thomas he was 29 and they
were married for four years and Janet
Jackson married James DeBarge when she
was 18 and he was 21. and a year later
they have their marriage annulled